think B vitamins
PMDD is rooted in hpa access dysfunction
during this half of your cycle
find a community
and their impact on serotonin and aloe
during your Lew to your face
and as it is so poorly researched
when you get there no one really knows what to do
you're more likely to feel low
meanwhile you are feeling awful all throughout the second half of your cycle
saffron can be amazing
it isn't necessarily about having high or low hormones
considered Calcium supplementation
Chamomile Rodeola
and lastly set clear boundaries with your friends and family
extortionate
pregnant alone
so PMDD is a real sensitivity to those fluctuating hormones
the waiting list to even get to talk to someone about was symptoms is
so supplement wise
go to bed at the same time and wake up at the same time everyday
the drops the spikes the dips
angry and anxious
but more so the brain just being unable to cope with the sheer intensity
but when your blood sugars drop
number one balance your blood sugar
your blood sugar is already more likely to be dysregulated
number 2 regulate your nervous system
so what can we do
all of that has an impact on your sex hormones
and the action of these hormones
so PMDD what can we do to get you feeling better